كم وزن الأحذية الحمراء الكبيرة
ليست هي تلك التي كانت تفكر فيها نانسي سيناترا،
هذه الأحذية مصنوعة،
لا، هذه الأحذية مصنوعة لتتباهى
بأصحاب النفوذ في عالم الموضة، ويصممونها،
إنه حذاء أبله، أعطيهم 10
من أصل 10. حتى المؤثرين في  يتظاهر
سيث رولينز، مصارعو جيل الجد،
بدوس خصمه مرتديًا
حذاءً أحمرًا كبيرًا
منذ أن تم طرحه للبيع مقابل 350
دولارًا وتم بيعه بالكامل في دقائق.
لا يمكن لعشاق الموضة الصمت بشأن
الأحذية الحمراء الكبيرة التي ابتكرتها مجموعة Art Collective
Mis Chief التي تجعلك ترغب في ذلك.
للمسها، نعم، نعم، اكتشف YouTube Sneakerhead Steve
natto ذلك عندما ارتداها
في Sneaker Con وطلب بعض الأشخاص
لمس الحذاء، كيف يشعرون بأن
الجزء العلوي مرن ولكن
الجزء السفلي ليس بالتأكيد يقول ستيف
إنهم كذلك  كان يرتديها طوال اليوم
دون ألم، ويصفها مبتكرها
بأنها كرتونية، ويشير إليها البعض باسم
أحذية Astro Boy، وعلى الرغم من سهولة ارتدائها، إلا أنها يمكن أن
تتعثر إذا كنت لا ترتدي
مقاسك المثالي الذي حصلت عليه قدمي.  عالقة لذا كان علي أن أفعل، يجب أن
أفعل ما كان علي فعله يا رجل، الآن
يظهرون على الجميع بدءًا من Puss
في حذاء أحمر كبير إلى شخصية Boots
من Dora the Explorer إلى Tony soprano
مقترنة برداء حمام
أراد الناس شراءه  مباشرة من عرض موجز
ستيف، حصلت على ما يقرب من 800 900
ألف، وأعتقد أنني حصلت على ما يقرب من 13 أو 1400، لقد
استمروا في الارتفاع في الوقت الحالي، إنها
المشكلة، هل أنت مستعد للأحذية، فهم
ليسوا على وشك الحصول على الحذاء
الجيني CNN New  يورك
[موسيقى]